All right, so today I'm going to present a retrospective study trying to assess the benefit of the current standard of care in a specific population in CD30-positive peripheral T-cell lymphoma other than anaplastic large-cell lymphoma.
So, the current standard of care was set through the Echelon 2 study in this population that demonstrated superior both progression-free survival and overall survival with brentuximab-CHP compared to CHOP.
However, in the subgroup analysis, although smaller numbers and not power to assess for this, the benefit was not evident in the subpopulation of peripheral T-cell lymphoma NOS.